man kennt es das arbeitsgruppen meeting
die teamsitzung das kreativ
brainstorming im gemeinsamen austausch
sollen drängende probleme gelöst und
neue ideen geboren werden
doch alle tun nur so in wahrheit sucht
jeder seinen vorteil und schützt
gleichzeitig seine interessen ein
frustrierender leerlauf wir reden gegen
statt miteinander
und während verantwortung und
zusätzliche arbeitsbelastung ab gunter
dueck saß als manager bei ibm in
unzähligen meetings jetzt betrachtet er
unternehmen aus distanzierter
perspektive und fragt wie wir hat
schwarm funktionieren oder auch nicht
zum beispiel in den leidigen meetings
das ganze wird relativ wenig gesprochen
also praktisch man bespricht immer die
bereiche die da sind die bereiche die
nicht da sind werden nicht besprochen
zu meinem kummer kommt der kunde relativ
selten vor weil der ja nie da ist man
sagt immer der kunde steht im
mittelpunkt oder steht die unter uns
oder so aber das schwarm intelligenz ist
ein begriff aus dem tierreich gern
beziehen wir das auch auf kollektives
menschliches handeln
doch in der arbeitswelt mit ihrem
leistungsdruck und konkurrenz verhalten
handeln wir eher schwarm dumm dabei
könnte es funktionieren
die beispiele die es gibt sind immer so
dass er seine crew startet so als
richtiges team ja also welten um segler
die die von einem gemeinsamen ziel
beseelt sind dass man in sich fühlt als
gruppe ein gemeinsames schicksal zu
haben und gemeinsam eine sache reichen
zu wollen und die ist höher als das
eigene selbst das mag beim roten kreuzes
einem baum ortsverein also dass das man
sich nicht so selbst teil im vordergrund
sondern irgendwie sagte ich bin für
etwas da
die bienen arbeiten instinktiv zum wohl
des ganzen ohne meetings und
leistungsziel
wir dagegen sind individualisten setzen
unsere persönlichen einzelinteressen vor
das langfristige wohl des ganzen ein
beispiel fahrer wird und kosmetikerin
sollen ein dorffest organisieren
der pfarrer bild sich als führungskraft
profilieren plädiert für einen
gottesdienst mit chorgesang unter seiner
leitung der wirbt will kasse machen
mit rambazamba im partyzelt beim bier
wurst und bunter
die kosmetikerin sucht das
gemeinschaftserlebnis mit karaoke disco
und schminkt wettbewerb im endergebnis
läuft alles auf den kleinsten
gemeinsamen nenner hinaus ein fauler
kompromiss mit dem keiner richtig
glücklich wird warum muss es so weit
kommen
was läuft falsch wieder um
einzelinteressen dabei also praktisch
das dass man keine gemeinsame
gemeinsames gefühl das sieht man
irgendwie überall also praktisch dass
das
einzelne leute sehr feste vorstellungen
haben wie wiesenfest zustande kommen
soll oder was es sein soll und sie
denken dann an bestimmte kundengruppen
nicht deswegen sage ich immer man
braucht so eine gewisse vision wozu das
eigentlich ganz gut ist ja und wenn man
wenn man gefühl hat wofür das fest ist
wenn das ja alles in ordnung
im alltag funktioniert das gut wie auf
dieser kreuzung
die vision ist der zügige verkehrsfluss
fußgänger tram und autos ordnet sich
diesem ziel unter so müsste es auch bei
unternehmen sein
besser man hat eine gemeinsame vision
über die produkte dies relativ klar was
das ist nämlich der kunde selbst also
ich gebe dem kunden was für ihn sinnvoll
ist fertig das gilt vielleicht nicht den
größten gewinn aber das funktioniert es
steht immer zur diskussion eine sache
die simpel funktioniert so wie hier die
bienen versus was über stress was zu
viele disharmonien zwei dieser gierige
ansatz scheint irgendwie für normale
männer doch erfolgreich versprechen
hatte sein als sowas harmonisches wenn
hier ehrgeiz und misstrauen in meeting
zusammentreffen ist die nächste schwarm
dummheit garantiert